the moon was nothing compared to the
earth earth was it was the the
centerpiece it was all there was
we had an emotional I suppose a rope
attaching us to planet Earth
for whatever reason it was what we
wanted to look at I mean tiny little
thing you could make it go away by
holding your thumb out at arm's length
but if you put your hand down
there it was again it wanted to be
looked at the blue of our oceans of
white of the clouds little streaks of
kind of a reddish tan things that we
call continents very shiny very bright
very beautiful and and yet strange
though it may seem the overriding
quality well a beauty I guess I would
say but lurking right behind Beauty was
a sense of its fragile it's a fragile
little thing out there the more you
discover that fragile is not a bad word
it is fragile it's it's fragile in
thousands of different ways most of
which are not too good sometimes we
humans don't seem like we really deserve
to live on this nice little thing you
see from quarter of a million miles out
[Music]
Oh